incredible I've never experienced
this why doesn't everyone talk about
this movie all the time this is why
reaction videos were
made can't wait for you to sit like this
well let's see what would that look like
hold on I do need to kind of just test
it for a second okay but it's full short
so we okay I don't think that's a great
look a it's it's a very suggested what
about this it does look very weird I
think you use it if I have to if you if
you decide
to you're in shorts I am in shorts it'll
be the beginning of this video all right
I'll just declare that I'll say you for
C citizens of the reject Nation since
orphan went over so well with the
audience we're immediately following
that up with orphan first kill of course
rejoined by Roxy stri who after looking
at our videos over the past year I will
W the real rejects scream Queen what
yeah I didn't know you were going to do
that there you go I'd like to thank my
dead
mom my dad I I think we should thank
them too all members of the
dpcc dpcs yeah you know me I'd like to
thank this company for making this
shorts because they know that I can't
close my legs on the show for too long
intro
complete but she was trying to say was
cuz she'll sit like this and it became a
whole conversation of like maybe today
we got be like but you're in shorts so
you know all right I'm a SC leave a like
on the video be sure to subscribe click
that notification Bell tell us in the
comments do you like this one is it
better than the last one leave your
thoughts down below thank you to prepper
for helping us set it down these
highlights full link through action
watch long where you sink up with your
own copy of Orphan first kill available
for super sex re just cover our patreon
page John and I cover several things
exclusiv over there with highlights and
watch Longs included can't keep her legs
closed so wow that was the most
unbelievable thing I've ever why it turn
into we'll just say you up a comment to
protect you and then you just double
down said like
nope
I got every single prediction I had
wrong yeah for the first movie well get
ready to get it all right because it's a
prequel so might be a little more
predictable did you write this one also
like the last one mhm take credit for
everyone's
material e w so you wrote Passion of
Christ I wrote Passion of Christ too
Jesus Strikes Back
[Laughter]
oh the
font we don't know that much about Ester
that's the point of the prequel I know
we know about the fire but that was a
little
later Estonia where's that is that
Russia well we knew she was from Estonia
but I I want to say that it's not Russia
it's Estonia is that a different country
I want to say yes it's not a
city comment below something we could
easily
Google I've never felt this dumb before
why I've never heard of Estonia Estonia
is a real like known place is it a
country or a city I think it's a country
continent definitely not a
continent yeah sain Institute which is
what we were calling calling
calling yes yes yes do you know yeah hey
mirroring the last one
remember she was watching from
outside arms
up first movie started off like a dream
was a dream and there is a dreamlike
quality here welcome are you ready for
your first day do you leave far somewhat
but it's worth it always wanted to use
art to help people wonderful I was
hoping she said where she would live so
we would know yeah out here on this
continent
Donia doer it's Lena she's not in the
room nobody can find her so get quick
Kenny Lo
it whoa do you remember what they said
Esther's name was I think it who they
just named
yeah this is a great day one on the job
who's Lena our most dangerous patient
your predecessor underestimated her and
ignored the protocol do not leave this
room you will be safe here and come back
after we found her oh man I feel like
this one could be just a fun team Esther
movie She's definitely in there right
for
sure oh yeah we see her in the
background what are we hearing hello
there hello there oh no does your mom or
dad work
here it's crazy cuz she had to be two
years older shooting this one than the
first one right yeah that would make
sense based off of how time works oh
she's going to stab her with the
pencil is that me wow you cook that up
quick I'm Anna what's your
name oh is she going to do it yeah she's
going to do it you're
right Lena oh no do your parents work
here why would you think
that cuz you're and what
oh
no put it down put it down
now the people in the comments taught us
last time that Leonardo DiCaprio said if
they didn't cast this girl he was going
to take it to different Studios that she
was like the only one all the auditions
they Poss could cast yeah well he was
trying to imprint so that way when she
turned a certain age he could finally
dat her somebody else in the comments
wrote that
too she struggled so hard against her
restraints that she would bleed severely
much of Lena's early life was spent
doing whatever she could to
survive reactions are real there's no
cutting 2 years ago this family took her
in they fed her Elena would simply steal
whatever she could and then disappear
appear but this
time well she lives here now did they
establish how old she is here they said
that she's 31 so this is only just two
years prior that is an interesting
timeline trajectory to do this two years
later and then only because she looks so
much older but it is what it is you know
it's not much they could have done about
that she's not still what an interesting
child actor
role oh
what did she show her that
white she just knows how to trigger she
stolen yeah longer dadd a few minutes
darling you Le Me by heart little S no
Daddy shle Temple I know you by heart
you're outside my heart and that's where
she got the idea I love Shirley Temple
ah so so the implication was to emulate
Shirley Temple hello dri you're on
time on time for what creep nature is
developing delivering
packages oh my God that is disgusting
he's so creepy I want to do something
nice for
you you can come
in yeah yeah ew e this is what what I'm
saying I get she's 31 but you don't
think this is creepy what part what did
you think I would if I this of course
this is
creepy Greg you don't think this
is assumption place it's weirdo into
this you are
Greg I mean it's obvious he part of his
turn on is the fact that she looks
really young that's what I'm saying is
the creepy part or she going to get his
gun
she going to bite him dad has
toen there it is there it
is see I'm kind of surprised by that
because she did want to hook up with an
older guy right like that's was the
dream it wasn't just about hooking up
with an older guy it was about uh the
element of like the father and stuff
yeah well he could have been her daddy
no he's Soo much of a too
weak oh [__] Esther's on a road trip I
thought it was just going to take place
in here the whole time but where at here
in this Asylum but maybe where and what
a road trip oh um
estabon
stonia whoa people in manal asylums are
crazy she did get scared just now we
haven't seen her remote
much kind of looks like a Saw movie now
whoa that was a camera there was weird
yeah oh she here she's fast
stealthy and impossible to make out a
silhouette behind a door yeah it is so
fuzzy yeah it looks a little bit more
like a Saw movie yeah that glow it
has somebody's going to come
in so you think that was her first kill
the basion of the head oh yeah I didn't
think about it like that yeah it's a
pretty cool tracking shot though that
they've been
[Music]
doing confidence
K do you want some
candy smart
sticker sticker on
him
you have to give her the candy that's
not
nice she will give her candy
right oh she's letting everyone go yeah
man save she has morals that's what we
call the save the cat Mo right
there now I can root for Esther as she
murders I mean I rooted for her for the
tire tire last movie you were te- master
in a very different way than I was oh no
this is where drive
forward what are you doing out of the
car what are you doing I'm so sorry Anna
hopefully the police will find her
before anyone else is hurt not quite the
start we had hoped for I'm sure this job
isn't for me really seems like a
cakewalk
oh so Esther's in her car right that
would be really silly if Esther's just
in there I'm for it though that's got to
be what it is right of
course to put this in like a prequel
perspective for Esther it really changes
the kind of genre it is like it's more
of like a campy
slasher well because in the last movie
it's the mystery about who she is right
wow so she's about to get out of the
trunk or what's
up B
it yeah okay damn Roxy your predictions
are on point she did not bother to check
to see now if Esther was in your car now
that I'm not blinded by my my obsession
with the fact that as's a child I can
actually predict the movie or it's a
fake out no it's definitely not a fake
out Esther popped out obviously she's
either under or she's coming
around
no yeah yes oh Esther who are we going
to root for for Esther to like there's
got to be someone
we and nobody's going to be looking for
her cuz she quit the
[Music]
job kind of feels like a foreign film
for film a foreign film I was going to
say what you watching Craig very
specific
taste Esther always knew how to play the
[Music]
piano she just taking her identity
yeah
what a wild plan well now she has a
house honestly I would kill for a house
too oh
Anna it usually takes only one jeez jeez
she said usually so I don't feel like
that guy was her first kill right and
she got into this place so she obviously
killed before I think first kill is just
a title to uh make us like watch a
prequel yeah I'm just
saying
Bo so you don't be frightened I'm please
you're lucky it was just a cop who
showed up where are your parents my
parents are in
America what is your name my name is
Esther okay I'm going to drive you to
America okay we know where Connecticut
is it is a
country let's go let's go
go is this not Esther no this is a tall
person yes Esther's known for her
height Julia Styles Save the Last Dance
if Roxy wasn't self-conscious about her
skirt she'd be doing her Save the Last
Dance pose right now for
sure when I move you move gunar works
his tail off when he's not studying he's
fencing he's living his
life she wears the bow like Esther I
need you to be present Gunner needs you
oh sorry was I not at that match mr's
not coming back Alan
ah every moment of every
day what a weird infiltration plan
wouldn't a DNA test say otherwise very
quickly I mean I don't think she's going
to will she be convinced it's their
daughter or will they just randomly
adopt
her Moscow Russia not Estonia different
country it's the first thing we're
Googling when we're done my mind always
thinks Julia Styles is 21 years oh yeah
that's what I was going to say the
21-year-old Kiron dunce is what I always
imagine a woman abducted her brought her
to Russia and passed her off as her own
child until Esther managed to escape
what she needs right now is our family
be prepared for changes 4 years is a
long time in the development of a child
oh the might just think she grew up a
little
bit
fortunately she looks a lot like the
missing child I know but she looks a lot
like her you
probably
Mis it's
me it's Mommy it's not my favorite line
maybe that's because I don't have a mom
Greg rob it in why don't
you would you be able to know four years
isn't that long I mean you could be
clouded by your grief it's been so long
since you've seen any of us there's
daddy this was one of charity events
they loaded your brother's probably a
foot taller oh there's mmup she's been
so good to us oh I can't wait to see her
she passed remember it's just the four
of us now yeah totally yeah she did say
she's been so good to us over there no
it's just right back over there that was
kind of a misleading way of saying [__]
she took vodka with
her let the games
begin get your head in the game
master you're going to smell the
v no Esther it's kind of like watching
plot points of Esther's plan play out
from the first movie but from her
perspective this time this movie is so
creepy cuz now we know you look like a
little
lady take this off that's better it's
less
AER this
is sorry no I I'm sorry I this is such a
weird dynamic well cuz if you're her mom
you're wondering what the have happened
to her for the last like she was
abducted yeah and then you were told you
got to keep a respectable you got to be
have boundaries yeah as she adjusts I'm
nervous all right big step
was that the dad in the photo in her uh
yeah last
movie there has to be something like a
mole or like something like a scar this
is a cruel plan of hor I mean oh my God
it's like a similar thing of like taking
advantage of a grieving family but even
worse
because
glad you're back me too how about we go
home yes like DNA test bro I mean would
you care to would that be your first
thing yes your first thing would be I
need a DNA test or or would you just go
oh my God I would like I would like to
think that I would know if it wasn't my
child for four years it's not 14 years
but she I mean she looks enough alike
though four years though come on if I
don't see you for four years I'm going
to be like I'm going to need a DNA test
if Roxy I was your kid bro in four years
would you develop an accent it
can okay but let me let me just run
something by you she could have stopped
here like in just sure yeah I just lived
out of
life
inance we have a lot of Christmases and
birthdays to make up for so let us know
what you're into and you might get it I
like painting you were never interested
in painting before you learn a lot in
child traffic trafficking
apparently you got really good at yeah
it's quite an educational experience
here tomorrow you're going to talk to Dr
Seager well if you need anything we
right down the hall all right like
you're just going to leave her be I mean
I don't think they win parents of the
Year award I I can't even begin to
understand like what how you would yeah
but it's not her bro yeah but they don't
know that I'm saying they should check
her ears check her fingers like there's
no check her ears
what you like you this is somebody you
bathed you know where their bird I feel
like there would be a bit of an
instinctual I feel like there' be a bit
of an intuitional feel like something
off where do you have a scar um I don't
I think um my body's perfect no my body
perfect body B with a six-pack welcome
home well now you're certainly not the
little girl I once knew you have no IDE
bit I was adopt I mean abducted do you
remember what I told you when we first
began our session I told you if I ask
any question questions that make you
uncomfortable we'll stop why was she in
therapy before they keep asking what
happened to me but I'm not ready to tell
them about it and that's perfectly fine
I am hoping you'll talk to me about it
but only when you're ready think that
parent's going to die I think the
parent's going to die you want to play
Sydney I think Sydney wants to play with
me hello I remember you you remember me
remember you how old's that bird
remember she said remember she's the one
with the parrot is what her mom style
said to her oh yes this is why you're
here to pick up on the
details what are you
writing I'm
sorry it's okay I'm sorry this kid's
getting a lot from that
mirror that's a cool
shot she seemed the same as you remember
different she she has an accent now you
asked that
question I did notice some
inconsistencies Sydney was a maau yet
today she addressed this bird as Sydney
with complete
confidence to me it felt like a
performance he hit me and ripped my
dress I want to go home we
[Music]
reschedule
they have to do I already want an orphan
3 where she's still alive somehow from
the water yeah not subtle at all you got
to know how to take photos of girls
without them noticing what happened to
this actress she is so effing gooda got
Gunner for me would you what did you
call me Mike that's her sister oh [__]
called her mortia you said she looked
like Wednesday Adams last
time
is that Spanish or
something your sister's a trip man
seriously dude my dad's right there I
don't
care back to the bullying older brother
a rich family to take me in and ask no
questions I know God you think we being
in
dpcs we' have the
opportunity what's the light for you
don't remember it's what your Papa's
famous for
we should take a drink every time
someone's like you don't remember yeah
yeah they're using it a
lot that's where she learned the
NightLight thing yeah I always try to
fit so much into one canvas you know so
I resorted to a a hidden layer so she's
10 now so she was six this guy's going
to go through some serious heartbreak if
he ever finds out oh
no I should have gotten rid of this who
is that there's no use delling on the
past your home now that's all that
matters right there the guy taking
pictures the detective yeah but the
detective probably doesn't believe that
that's where she's really back I want to
draw you I can I can do the Thinker the
way you were when you were looking at
that that's not a place I want to live
anymore you learned to paint while you
were over there mhm yes because I'm 31
so I'll see you at the Galla tomorrow
then okay it's for a good cause just
bring your checkbook and Jim it's for
Pediatric cancer for Christ's sake Maybe
cancel every event you've ever had
because your daughter is home I'm
finished it's interesting because I I
like this Dynamic more with the dad than
I did in the last movie
already it's not going to be as easy
because he thinks you're blood daughter
you know Master her it's an obstacle
though you know Noe it's a challenge but
if anyone could overcome this challenge
it's need you not to go there right now
Greg need you not to go there es can do
it that's private oh I'm sorry I I was
looking for my gold watch good
lie oh she's reading her old oh this
will help
her mommy took me to hello Mommy
thank you Mommy I know Mommy she's going
to be able to say I remember when we
went to Wicked you know he book her
she's going to have to look up
everything that happens in Wicked This
is delicious
mommy is something
wrong no no I'm I'm
just wow she really is like a great
she's unreal yeah this is a police
officer who helped us when you on
missing he's a friend I just uh came to
say welcome home eser is that the
tagline of the movie welcome home
welcome home Esther Esther did vanish
from our little town and that remains a
concern I need to know if there's still
a
danger I spoke to Dr Seager this morning
a danger like of under kidnappers she
told me she's open to a group discussion
tomorrow morning your g is tomorrow
we'll do it the following day then it's
important you forgot to fill your glass
but in the last movie she remembered to
get the soda can this she learned her
mistake she grew
she oh oh
oh Esther no this is not the path is
happening no don't kill the the rat is
she thinking of running
yeah no don't please don't she's not
going to kill the rat she loves the rat
why would she love it
[Music]
oh thank God why would she kill the rat
because she's crazy she is a
rat Oh
no just check out what he's drawing it
might be you oh this is interesting
because she's she's actually like truly
emotionally drawn to
him she goes back there's a there's like
a oh what she going to say to the there
a twisted tenderness that's going to
form for that's
interesting the the part that's kind of
lacking for me is how like ver fora the
the mom was like phenomenal and I I feel
like Julia Styles's character is well
she just doesn't seem to care that much
that she's home she doesn't seem like a
character to me you're coming of course
I'm coming get my wife I can deal with a
few Rich for you and what about Esther
well Gunner's here be fine right uh oh
it's crazy they got Den villanu to play
the
dad are we
communicating that's not
him oh yeah let's go through the Beats
oh my God those are amazing oh as's GNA
see it I know yeah let's go through the
beats that remind me of the other movie
yeah the other movie
stuff oh my god wow that is really
graphic she just close the door she
ripped her dress why didn't you close
the door what is with you neglectful ass
parents and and doing stuff oh my god do
you know how much I spent on this dress
I think you can afford another one no
it's tonight you don't think she owns
another dress you have no idea what it
is to be a
woman uh I can I can imagine
struggles we're off probably won't be
home till after midnight okay so don't
let her stay up too late copy that what
was he wearing so what are we going to
do
we this is the world's worst
brother I don't get
why he I feel like he would give a
little bit of a [__] yeah I know it it's
sister yeah and he's old enough it's not
like he's eight it's not the adopted
sister I don't buy you as like you're my
missing my sister who's been missing for
four years like she's different all
right she's got an accent now she
dresses like Lizzie bordon it's so weird
I hate you who's ly
Bon some crazy chick who killed her
parents with an axe uh Hey
Esther that kid is a winner this is new
your scene go watch a movie go yourself
oh team Esther he has no idea what she's
been through my parents aren't here
throughout mom's Gala just my
luck having a party he knew that the
parents were going to the gala he wanted
to interrogate Esther why don't I just
tell my parents that you stop by and we
can just forget all about this mind if I
H hit the restroom before I go this kid
sucks I know he's awful like like and so
awful he's not
believable what is she about to
do I feel like there's a hidden camera
in her room or like a bug or something
what year is this what does that matter
cameras hidden camera like they could
still have one right 2,000 I don't know
we don't see any cell phones so
let's hope the house is still standing I
mean when I was 16 I I
nearly I nearly put the house down
foreshadowing ugly
dress she going to a
funeral I see the notebook oh
no F left it there on purpose though
isn't it just a
Bible no with the pictures and the notes
and stuff that she writes in it right or
at least later on there something like
egregiously terrible or something you
know oh we'll
see it's pretty bad Greg it's a little
bad this is not good Greg s
Institute you would think with like this
level of wealth and investigation they'd
be like be on alert Russian police there
what's about to happen what's about to
happen Greg what's about to happen
what's about to happen she's going to
take a shower no no no the guy's dead in
there the guy is
dead you think she would kill the
detective here no Esther's not in there
though what do you think's going to
happen I don't know but nobody's in the
shower and it's running she she knows
that Esther's there this is bad Greg
isn't this his home yes we just saw that
she had his address yeah yeah she's
going to murder him yes well aren't you
understanding Greg that's bad
fingerprints oh he took her prints dude
the DNA thing you
wanted
creepy okay you heard that though bro so
get up do detectives just have like at
home forensic stuff I don't know cuz I
just told you I didn't know if they were
webcam so what year are
we these came out in the early 2000s
right or mid 2000s I the first one was
in 2009 but this takes place two th two
years before it's got to be early as
2007 oh my god Becky look at her butt
who the hell are
you
whoa whoa right in the
the how did you know that I'm not this
sir
her mother doesn't even know she
suspects yeah kid she
[Music]
does what direction are we going down
with this this is very
unexpected are you looking at so let me
get this
straight you're a grown ass woman and a
wanted criminal that is beyond
up I suddenly very interested when gunar
told me Donan came to the house I knew
I'd find you here you could have robbed
us blind and disappeared the second you
had a chance but you didn't all my
criticism is about who her character is
suddenly went out the window you'll
never see me again that's exactly what
I'm afraid of we can't have Esther
disappear twice now can we did she
didn't disappear there was nothing that
I could do for
her what gunar he was always way too
rough with her that he just went too far
what was I supposed to do oh my
God the only child I had left over some
sibling [__] that went too far I
loved my daughter but a mother protects
her family no matter
what his family came over on the
Mayflower and built this country oh man
Allan matters when he got the news
Esther was alive the happiness on his
face I had to make this work clever
clever I doesn't know what happened to
Esther and you are going to help me make
sure that he never does there is only
one thing worse than the death of a
Child Jesus and that is a child who is
missing Esther's disappearance changed
Alan sadistic
you are the answer this is nuts man what
a surprise so is is that Gunner with her
Esther's down there isn't she don't you
say her name what a Twist I know you you
chose this role and now you're going to
play it even the Gunner thing makes more
sense now of his attitude I'm like wow
shocking and this is why she didn't care
when she's back you can be Esther for
now or you take the fall for this and
get shipped back to Estonia in handcuffs
that's why she was cold and suspicious
oh man the mom was so detached I was
like what a weird performance damn this
is now damn movie damn movie it went
from okay to awesome oh
[__] she fell off her bike I found her
by the side of the road come let's let's
get warm mom I'm so sorry stop oh my God
s she's going to become like a
hero but make it look like an
accident it's too soon we need to think
about this I I I love this so
much neither of us were expecting this
so for now we just keep an eye on her
and the time is right will end it
incredible oh my God this is why
reaction videos were made was for [__]
like this it was so intense and I told
you to shut up I was like I can't I
can't believe what we're watching right
now like that is so that was the most
unexpected thing never in a million
years yeah never but we picked up on all
the things like why is he being like
this why is she it just seem like
repetitive Al some of the blot be felt
repetitive from the last movie but it
was all like purposeful to throw you off
oh my God it wasn't lazy purpose
purpose unreal so so surprising our
meeting with Dr Seager is today a
problem we wouldn't have if you hadn't
talked to the parrot Sydney was a
maau all MAA are parrots not all parrots
are MAA helping her Blendon what's a
memory that means a lot to you and to
Esther there was uh Christmas in Paris
the summer in tusy I was six we saw bed
what else Esther wage Ranch and rode
horses mine was a pony named nugget and
Daddy's horse was called stretch so a
lot of facts daddy fell right over his
head onto the ground he had dir all over
his face it even in his tell story oh my
God it's working it's working the mom
and her conning the psychologist
together cuz all we had heard in the
next movie is that she had fooled them
there are people coming over today just
to see you does she have boobs is that
why they rap her always we are going to
pretend that pink is your favorite color
let's give them a story they want to
believe oh my God Julia Styles is so
believable too she's incred I've never
experienced this ever
before just like wow this drastically
switched everything everyone talk about
this movie all the time is this the best
movie ever
made and are your plans now young
lady what are my plans Mommy I am not
letting you out of my sight but the
problem with the game is Esther can't
grow I know that's why they're going to
kill
her who's in there is that Gunner
brother yeah are they going to start
hooking up Greg I don't know this movie
completely surprised me you're 30 get
out of my room now please it's my dead
sister's room you're not her and you
never will be okay you know I'm glad
everything's out in the open now cuz I'm
done pretending like you belong here you
don't you crazy
1centers I own
you do that again and I'll kill you like
I killed Esther oh my God I love his
gasp one call from me and you're right
back in that goog you'd go down too why
because of what the illegal immigrant
fugitive mental patient said because I
know where the body is [__] this is
America people like me matter and if
you're not Esther that just means
Esther's missing again mom has a problem
with
that I don't one percenters is is he as
bad of a person as she is I think yes
right yeah no I mean they're they're
worse they're worse than Esther in every
way not in every way he murdered his
sister and she covered the mom covered
it
up well I made your favorite a I'm
really excited about going into the city
tomorrow and what a way to strip Esther
away from her power
I've rediscovered the joy I once felt
doing what I love I feel like a kid
again you want to come I would love to
well Esther and I already have
plans another time then it's great that
you're painting again Dad wow what a
phenomenal actress yeah may I be excused
you can eat upstairs it's okay honey hey
what's wrong making her
eat she's going to throw it against what
is she going to oh the rat oh then she's
going to kill the rat that's not going
to kill the rat kill the rat there's
drugs in it the medicine remember Julia
Styles was pouring the medicine but why
would that kill the rat they were trying
to kill her this early I think Oh I
thought maybe it was like a slow burn
but the rat is small what happened down
there I don't really like mommy's
cooking can you keep a secret I'm not
crazy about it
either oh I like him so much I
don't oh there is like actual tender
bonding too
I am so impressed with this
movie who is he he's very good too he
directed Dune prisoners stop doing that
we get to see beauty
passion where others don't even know to
look I really like
that but she's like why isn't she dead
yet yeah so much paint yeah oh my God
and the and Julia ster get so
uncomfortable with this intimacy
cuz she knows it's like a 30-year-old
woman have a good
night man that's really a child actor
we're watching right now her yeah I mean
I know she's an adult now but damn like
very believable are you so utterly
delusional to think that he would want
you he would be as repulsed by you as I
suspect most men are oh my gosh she's
just in a prison again I'm going to go
upstairs and my husband Jesus Christ
same girl tell them how interesting like
I thought they were going to give Esther
some like me imagine that like this is
so crazy Greg this is so multi layered
because I mean now we know how effed up
she was but this is part of why I
thought we were going to give Esther
someone to victimize to make a victim
but like but instead they give her
someone to they gave her an enemy like
that's so such in in a way that's oh she
knows the rat's dead she's about to find
out the rat's de Greg of course the rat
you know whoever came up with this twist
probably was like I'm
the like I got
it oh it's too
bad I got to burn this house down I'm
going to make my usual smoothie greek
yogurt kale flax seeds and lemon juice
all this just cuz of the dad I'm I'm not
really that hungry I I'll am it here no
this is special just for Mommy I made it
for you man you thought I was rude for
eser before my God man I'm really rude
for her
now
delicious she is a dead rat in there you
okay I'm good
yeah you got to got to hide got to
covered up get covered up I love
it it is a cat and mouse game of these
two
DEA Woodley is a friend of mine
Woodley's the best art school in the
country you're scary good as can I show
it to him thank
you feel for her yeah that's what I I
was literally thinking how normally
something like this would make you go
all right they've I'm they beat the
whole Esther character to death at this
point but I'm like they've made her more
interesting how did they do that
normally like you get rid of the mystery
and they're not as interesting but I'm
like now she's more interested oh she's
looking at them what she going to do do
push them in the tracks oh my God Greg
Greg Greg you're not going to succeed
Greg
no oh my go you going P
off Jesus Christ what's for you going
kid she going to you yes she is what
happened our Arrangement is
over
hey
yeah [__] I mean he deserves to
die America open the goddamn door Esther
don't
you I think the editors of this like cuz
the movie is directed different it's
like more shock closer more handheld um
but the editing on this is really great
right like the way it's been ramping up
what happens from here she reported a
stolen cart like what's her game plan I
thought she burns the house down no I'm
saying what happened like right now her
mom's reporting a a stolen car all right
and she what is her game plan from here
she's going to burn the house down right
now oh my God this little actress meme
it is she trying to look older or what
is she trying
to I'm sorry was I driving too fast you
must be
Esther yep it's been reported I mean
there's constant lying and these
outbursts of anger and sometimes she
even jokes about s and I don't think
she's really
joking I love that Julia Styles knew the
role she signed up for she's like I'm
the villain in this
one but they're all the villains other
than the dad the dad is so nice nothing
nothing is worth having you in this
house oh my
god oh
no it's going to break daddy's
heart oh no oh my God the dad's going to
walk
in
nice is this where she burns the house
down just die you freak ouch nope nope
nope NOP oh no
flashback where is she I didn't mean to
oh that's just
brilliant it just
happened hi honey the police just called
me oh I know I'm oh no I'm sorry keep
eyes on
her I'm on the train hold
on she got up it's right Esther it's
right do what you got to do go
downstairs and finish it no sweetie I
swear everything is fine Esther is here
I was exhausted before
filming I I wide awake right now this
movie is
unbelievable oh my God he's putting on
his fening out he's put on his out freak
oh my
God no you should have kept it on I wish
could like a the actor negotiated his
contract so that his was seen during
this I'm sure we could figure something
out you really believe that what's
behind her no me Nei
[__]
[Music]
nice finish
it uhoh is the dad yeah no thank god oh
no oh she can but our Esther can show
Dad the Esther body what the Esther
who's like buried the real Esther yeah
yeah this is how the fire is going to
happen it's always funny to see people
movies like swinging like that I feel
like it be pretty easy to stab someone
when you got a
knife
Esther really earned getting into that
orphanage yeah look at what she
struggled with this is the thing too
like dads are so non observant that he
whatever I both movies the dads are a
little bit
naive this Dad especially my wife's a
psycho but is the dad going to
die yeah you think he's going to go into
the
house I I don't know actually man D so
Esther didn't technically Start the Fire
he will know who you are the deformed
freak who manipulated our grief murdered
my son why will he know cuz she's going
to tell him and tried to kill me until I
did what had to be
done she's going to say Daddy help oh
now it's Esther on the outside of the
house hiding
I think all the budget of the movie went
into the house and Julia
Styles yeah location location location
Greg and to the government of
[Laughter]
Estonia whoa was this movie in
3D Papa be like from a lot further away
he would have noticed the he just ran
right the in hey man he's trying to save
his
family hold on I'm coming that's an
interesting yeah oh he goes to save
Esther
first he can only save one who's he
going to save he obviously is going to
she's a grown woman me lying your daddyy
please help
me
oh [__] oh she just slipped yeah she
said she can't hold on much longer
Greg oh no this poor guy just got back
into painting
too is she going to push him no she
likes him yeah but she's I think she's
worried he's going to know Esther is
going to give him the
truth oh she's going to do it you're
right what the I did this for you for us
I love you you're monst
Al oh you're right damn oh it was an
accident she should have shown him the
truth about like eser if I were to
rewrite the movie which I know people
hate to here I think it like if she took
him to see where Esther's actual body is
pro that she's not Esther I know but it
would also reveal that the mom and the
brother and the some were like baths you
know he could have a little bit more of
a twisted thing where he lets her go I
think so that's
like they kind of just we got to kill
them
off that's the Glory of
Love get
adopted
crazy God I love
Flames sure people who have experienced
terrible fires love that
comment but Flames look so
beautiful mean you should present
yourself as like having a bit of a
struggle yeah fire took everything from
Esther her home family syester hasn't
been through enough already abducted and
now an
orphan orphan the title of the movie
I've reached out to a reputable adoption
agency I'm confident we'll find a home
oh my God after all who wouldn't want to
adopt her look at The Duality with the
mirror that's cool
oh my
god oh chills it's cheesy of a prequel
ending that is that is that is great
look likey I mean
I
boom so
impressed that last half saved the [__]
out of this movie in ways I could not
have fathomed and Justified the first
half next up a Wonderful Life what a
weird transition it works
look Prime video knows how to recommend
yeah it's a wonderful life if you like
Oran first kill whoa Greg that was like
I honestly I'm I hope it's so I don't
even know what I said or didn't say that
might be the most silent I've ever been
in a reaction I this actually had me
speechless at times uh yeah I was I
couldn't even I was shocked that was
crazy you know what else I'm shocked by
people who buy shirts from reject
naations shop.com we shouldn't be
shocked those shirts are dope you should
be expecting that cuz they're awesome
yeah keep saying things because we have
T-shirts flashing up on screen while
you're while you're talking and they
come in black and white and red
and I mean it's like we can't mislead
people some of them I have some it's
true they come in all different colors I
have gray one too mhm and it's the best
way to support the channel love to see
it and also you're listening to us apple
on Spotify we just watched orphan first
kill Greg joined with the scream Queen
Roxy ster over here that is
me okay number one where's Estonia is it
a country number two sure let's look I'm
GNA look that on my phone what is up
with this little actress what has she
done since then okay those are the we'll
talk about the movie first Estonia it's
a country in Europe it's country it's a
country it's an actual country I was
right about that thought it was a city
in Russia yep
okay okay okay I feel I feel better
about myself right now okay number two
can you please tell me what this little
actress does fine I will look that up
right now before we actually talk about
the actual movie itself well it's
relevant to the movie because she's the
star of the movie and this like I've
never seen I she might be the best child
actress I've ever seen my life Greg yeah
because she has to like Isabelle Ferman
she has to play and um an adult
pretending to be a kid and she she just
seems like
a like a real person at the same time
like she doesn't seem like a child
pretending to be an adult you know oh
look no nor does she come across like an
overly precocious kid or something like
that you have to use it I'm going to
look this up real
Qui I know how to look up
stuff taking way longer than I thought
it's oh my God
Ro just good thing you're going to go
watch found her so she's done you no
idea you don't what you're talking about
I got it right I forgot you guys have
told me about The Hunger Games that she
was clove you guys told me in the
comments that she did some kind of knife
throwing thing I don't remember her but
this girl should book everything damn
she's probably too old now to do like an
orphan three no she did an orphan 3
there's no orphan 3 in
development there's an orphan 3 in
development I don't know you know how
IMDb works sometimes sometimes they be
putting [__] in development that's not
actually in development is there an
orphan 3 oh my God Roxy if we can get a
final destination 6 and an orphan 3 oh
my God God we are sitting oh my God yes
it's in development but in what way is
it in development from December 2023
it's been in development wow wow this
girl is 26 years old now anyway do that
sh wow yeah like okay if you for some
reason you skip the Rea every once in a
while a movie comes along like I really
love the first movie yeah me too I I
think like the first movie is a is a
better
movie way uh just in like terms of like
an actual the the the structure the
overall execution like the way it's
directed and the writing like the like
actual writing of itself like it's not
Flawless there's definitely flaw in it
but you know like the surprises that
they had here in in that last one of
like the whole time we were like what is
up with and that that emotional back and
forth we were having that I think a lot
of the audience will debate with in that
first movie is part of what makes that
first one so compelling it is like I
don't know I kind of like her and you're
like she's traumatized I'm like I don't
know I feel she's kind of a suspicious
little little girl like that whole
mystery surounding her but on a sequel
SL prequel level a territory horror
films often dive
into this is one of the most impressive
ones to me completely because I think
that they really knew they had us they
knew in that moment everything's going
to make sense and it was like such a
generic script before then that was
almost annoying to the point where you
and I are just like Su with the mom and
the the brother they're not even I'm
like she's not looking for birth marks
why is he beinging such a dick he
doesn't even care all of it wasn't
making sense but the dad was being so
loving I was like what what is this that
twist made all that that first and
second act or whenever it came through
the first half makes sense and just so I
think that this is a better movie I
think this is better than the first one
I loved the first one but to me this did
something that it's so rare for a movie
to do to me and that shocked me but not
for shock effect like truly brilliant
writing so good I think though it needs
the first one because what the movie did
in such a self-aware way was know that
it's being a sequel prequel because the
first half of it is doing like like all
the [__] that you see in like prequel
sequel stuff like yeah this this beat
reminds me of the last movie this one
reminds me of the last oh it's like the
last movie but a little different here
uh they're kind of flipping the dynamic
a little bit and they and they have you
they they pretty much tell you at the
beginning like yeah this is going to be
uh Esther Unleashed that's what this
film's going to be oh she's going she's
adoped into the house or we're watching
the same movie we're just watching the
same movie uh but with some different
stuff and but but then once Julia Styles
shows up shooting the guy instantly
you're like
ah that wasn't what I was expecting to
happen what's going on and yeah I think
the what a scene that is I think in like
a like that kind of grungy aggressive
way the you've seen the Saw movies right
yeah not all of them but most of them
but you know how they this has kind of
those Saw movie flare to me where it's a
little bit more low lit and uh more
close up a little a little grung a
little like meaner in its display
whereas the first one looked a little
like prettier there's like a little
meaner and I love the I love a good Flo
have you seen the Devil's Rejects no
okay won't spoil it well anyway I the
Real's rejects actually the title was
inspired from that movie um I love a
Flippo where you're watching protagonist
you're you're where you're watching the
villain as the main character and then
suddenly you're like oh [__] now I
really care about the villain and not in
a way I was expecting because they gave
them a villain where they make things
really multiat because you're like but
Esther's still technically doing
something wrong you know like what she's
doing was is bad but now I feel bad for
her and and the way they flip the power
Dynamic where she's back to being is
essenti
imprisoned and and forced to do things
that she doesn't want to do I thought
was yeah there's so many things about
this that I absolutely love though yeah
yeah I I think that the first one did a
great job like you're talking about is
keeping us guessing like you felt one
way I felt another I'm sure audiences
are split about how they're feeling
what's happening most people probably
with you on that one like okay
something's really wrong with her but
you're not sure what the whole time and
you know you don't know you know you
don't know what's under the the ribbon
on her neck you know you don't know
what's under her wrists you know you
don't know enough about Esther this
movie convinces you you know everything
and so you feel confident like oh I know
what I'm watching unlike the last movie
I had no idea I keep guessing this movie
is like oh no you now know her so you
know what's up so I wasn't looking for
something like a Twist I was thinking
yeah now I know her I know this movie so
I'm in which is why when they do the
bait and switch and hit you with that
scene with the mom coming in and then
shooting the guy you're just like
what yeah you guys just told me I knew
what was going on and I did not know
what was going on and it wasn't a like
oh we're in the Final Act it it was like
the last half of the movie which which I
love so much because I I feel like a lot
of movies might have just made similar
how the last movie gives you that reveal
like 20 minutes before it ends this
movie doesn't do that they they have
their midpoint is just like all right
just when you think you know what this
movie is nope you're wrong so I thought
it's smart and and I think for Esther
too like the I was saying during the
reaction of like the this character is
someone where a big part of what made
her work so much in the last movie was
the the you know the WTF surrounding her
like who is this person exactly like we
know something's up with her but who is
she and then they tell you so you think
that like by pulling back the mirror and
and letting you hang out with her as the
protagonist and her perspective that it
would actually dilute her character but
it just made her so much more
interesting and
and her backstory more intriguing and
and it is it does make for a good
companion piece on to the to the to the
prior movie yeah what a perfect onew
punch yeah the first movie was great and
I for me this movie was just as great if
not better equally built on that but
they're so different and a lot of
sequels just are the the original I
guess it was a prequel not a sequel but
a lot of the second movie to come out is
just given us it in a little variety of
it and this was like actually we're
going to do something totally different
cuz some people out there be effed up
too yeah not just Esther so good great
casting Julia Styles too man she awesome
I thought you was like man she's so
boring and then sudden I'm like who
you're like you're creepy as hell woman
that son too he could definitely be in
any of these teen drama shows where
you're just the the rich
prick I'm into this I'm so into this I
would love an orphan 3 I don't know how
they would do it somehow I feel like
they would find a way to pull off I feel
like the last movie had a bigger budget
you had DiCaprio producing it you
had I don't think he produced this one
and like this felt like lower budget
where so I think like they were able to
do like cooler shots like the car
sequence with the daughters in the in
the car in the last movie so I think
they were able to do like cooler looking
sequences um but for what this places in
terms of like squel prequel it is it is
a wildly impressive
uh installment I got know the Rotten
Tomato score can we look that up yeah
for both of them yeah yeah I don't know
I don't know for any of them actually
let's find out yeah I'm curious about
the Rotten Tomato score I'd also would
be curious about the budget or are you
kidding me orphan is a
58 waack sauce and even the audience
score of 63 that's weak bro ah but this
was like at I mean I feel like horror
movies have a lot more respect now
there's a time where it's like oh your
horror screw you and I thought the last
movie was a little this is higher with
the audience not as many people voted
but damn this higher on critics yeah
quite a bit 71 yep because that was just
brilliant what they did yeah see I think
what they did um here which I thought
was an improvement was there W I felt
that they were
self-aware unlike the last one where I
was kind of laughing at it this movie
genuinely felt like really self-aware
I'm back and forth I'm back and forth
there are things about it where I'm like
I like I like certain parts of the the
specifically the directing and
cinematography a little bit more in the
first one yeah I I like that too but in
terms of like a just an
experience I think I like my experience
with this one more did orphan first kill
come out on Paramount plus might have
been some Paramount plus yeah didn't
feel as big of a movie what year was it
uh the release date was
2022 did it just come out last year wait
look up when I thought the first one
came out in
2009 oh man we were way wrong people
have probably playing Common Police with
us the whole
time oh damn so she was she still looks
that young we were here the whole time
13 year age Gap we were here the whole
time sounding like being like Oh the
most fil this just like two years after
oh my
God damn we were way off well then she
looked amazing that's incredible like oh
they put a lot of powder and they did a
lot of wow we just got to see that's
weird at like events and stuff she looks
like in her 20s how were they able to do
that I mean maybe this came out last
effing year must have something to do
with her height because yeah she like
definitely looks like she's in her 20s
and like these actual events and stuff
wow she's 26 but so last year she must
have been 25 was how do they do
that well let's look what she looks like
in the first
movie oh she definitely looked a lot
younger she did look a lot younger yeah
but I said that a few times she looked a
lot younger but not in 13 years the
performance she was giving
yes uh yeah well that makes it even
better our whole experience like dude
this child actor's
insane she's still a great she's still a
great actress this wow do what she had
done 13 years prior that's hard too she
had to circle back to 13 years
experience just keeps getting more
Amplified holy [__] oh my go cuz she
still looks like a a little kid she she
still looks like really really
young wow but damn yeah she does look
like an adult and like actual you know
adult stuff even so no wonder so was a
straight to Paramount plus movie was it
that's what it looks like last thing we
got to look up then we got to get you
out of here got you got a place to go
wow Greg this is the movie that twists
and terms until we can't even wow orphan
first kill theatrical release it might
have just been a straight to Paramount
plus movie it was simultaneously
released damn that was a blast okay whoa
all right so we have that how did they
do that we have this movie okay man we
we can get orphan 3 and Final
Destination 6 possibly we're like how
are they going to do orphan 3 now oh cuz
they did this one last year bro duh yeah
they got to do orphan 3 I know yeah we
were like it's been too long and she
probably aged up too much oh [__] wow
that totally affected our our viewing
experience didn't it we were just like
what I'm glad I didn't know and it would
also make sense why they would have a
lower budget after that many years for
sure cuz it wasn't like we got to follow
this up right away also I was thinking
about that during the movie and I was
almost going to say wow it's so weird
because Julia Styles looks exactly the
same I I almost said that like four
times and I was just like don't say that
Roxy because it's been over a
decade wow that is
shocking okay cuz I'm like what's this
guy done since what's the dad I'm like
that's crazy they're all so good why
aren't they working since in 10 years oh
my God yeah it's
true all right last thing to look up
last thing who's the dad that's the last
thing I want who's your
daddy uh I'm DPC
boom bring it back feel bad for us but
we're going to act like you should have
feel
bad
um orphan no mouse you're right this is
a shitty Mouse people people complain
about this mouse and it's true it is a
really bad M really that's Alfred Molina
there that is not him okay Canadian
actor keeps scrolling he went to
Princeton cool cool I said I thought he
was in a show handmade's tail that's the
show he's in he's as sh him Isel okay
dope yep dope stuff dope stuff that
makes sense all righty guys well what
did you guys think about orphan first
kill leave your thoughts down below were
you as shock as we wow that is I was
like if they don't say they're shock
they're liars I'm sorry if you if you
didn't see that before and you aren't
surprised then you are a bace liar I was
like I am genuinely GL can you imagine
watching this without a camera pointed
at i' been like oh now I got to
communicate that experience to people
not the same
thing um that was crazy that was crazy
uh leave your thoughts down below leave
a like get a shirt and um follow Roxy
and let us know what else we should
watch trolls what yeah horror movies and
the trolls franchise it's all I got for
Roxy guys sorry that we need other
movies for you uh did you do the help I
did do that didn't do that yet did I no
that went up
okay did I film that all righty see you
[Music]
guys